pasadena california
home to the kingston cafe an authentic
jamaican restaurant owned by dr yuna
morris who not only is a practicing
radiologist but as a three-time olympian
all my life i was able to accomplish the
things i really wanted to do and so i
started the restaurant because i really
enjoy cooking and there were no other
jamaican restaurant around one negril
jam steak medium rare you know my son is
a manager but we don't necessarily see
things eye to eye kiane please be quiet
i'm talking she doesn't really listen to
my suggestions and i've gotten to a
point where i can't deal with this
everything has to be cooked to order
that's
she's focusing on small details like
tablecloths being an inch off it's not
even see one side over there is long and
yellow but the biggest focus should be
why don't we have any more customers
i still see buses
all of these have to change see you have
to set standard if you don't set
standard how you expect something to run
well these knife and forks are
unacceptable and i don't like how some
of these look you see
sorry dr morris like everyone gets a bit
nervous when she's around even myself
they need their food now there are four
people out there haven't even gotten a
second yet
lots of cooks come in and out they're
there for one day then you never see
them again remember the salt is one of
the most important things not everybody
can cook jamaican food we can't sell
this i don't like how it tastes at all
it's kind of hard for someone to expect
you to do a job and then they keep
stepping in and not allowing you to do
it mom mom you gotta you gotta let him
work that's not gonna happen when she's
in the kitchen it slows things down this
cannot be like this the planting is
hanging over the edges
it creates a conflict when getting
plates out and then we have to deal with
the customers who are not happy sorry
about the wheat
it's cold the restaurant's drowning
and we're all going down with it we
don't get no customers be lucky if you
get five tables in all day i know it's
bad in it
if it doesn't change soon it's it's
gonna die
i cannot sleep because i have so much
debt
and my money from my retirement has
almost dried up
keone convinced me that gordon ramsay
would help the restaurant something has
to be done
chef ramsey is my last resort
[Music]
after a phone call early this morning
chef ramsay decides to make a detour
before heading to the restaurant hisa
i'm all right good to see dr morris's
son keone has requested a meeting and
chef ramsay has obliged
how's it going um difficult times ready
for sure probably doing about 30 of what
we're doing over the summer wow
what's the number one problem
tony in the restaurant what is it i
would say my mother's management ready
well she's very much a micro manager and
likes to roll with the iron fist if i
implement something she would get angry
and she would want to implement her
version of way of doing things
mixed messages and more importantly how
confusing for not just the customers but
for the team
exactly like you have to realize like
she came from jamaica essentially by
herself she's a physician in radiology
okay
she's been to the olympics olympics yes
that is one disciplined woman right so
she's tough yeah absolutely how tough on
a scale of one to ten 35
geez yeah my mom what she says goes and
it definitely does have its strain on
the business
it looks like a
residence
i would have driven right by it
hey mom that's too small that is too
small you can't say okay i got another
one let's go let's go
we're gonna take over here
[Music]
hello
how are you good nice to see you just
went hardly recognizes the restaurant
there
looks like a house on the outside it
doesn't look like a restaurant very
homey uh where are we going i'm going to
the me dining room okay
right it's a strange entrance hello
dr morris how are you i'm really blessed
seeing you i'm sorry to catch your name
my name is yuna but everybody has called
me doc morris wow okay doctor good to
see you what's that in there
that's chloe gold excellent who made
that the chef under the supervision of
me wow i know you're always in the
kitchen or i-i do everything just to
make sure everything runs okay right
lose the head chef that would be me
young man nice to meet you and first
name is daniel the menu was designed by
are you doing yes
good to meet you all
i can't wait to taste it
thank you
thank you very much and you're super
we'll be back thank you
wow
bizarre menu
like something i have an office spoiling
cabinets hi there
how you doing brother how are you i'm
very well thank you matthew great accent
thank you how long have you been here
almost two years i met dr maurice dr
morris can be a little overbearing
sometimes it's just the way she wants
everything to be perfect why do we have
to call a doctor uh that's just
she's dr morris but even in a restaurant
yes the doctor's office is next door
what literally next door literally next
door what a headache oh believe me i
think she's really taken on too much i
personally think she's slowly but surely
running herself into an early grave we
have salad that need to take out now
it's fermented it doesn't matter it
needs to be now we're taking it right
now so i'll go for the uh jamaican
patties one veg i want beef
got to got to go to have the hot flashes
okay
which is your jerk chicken right that's
our signature dish yeah it looks like
you're having some hot flushes you're
right yeah it's fine here is it yeah
plus it's wearing this get up as well i
mean i feel like i'm at a funeral
sometimes when i come to work
wow wow wow wow famous chicken married
in secret joke sauce what's the secret
behind it uh the owner of the restaurant
makes the sauce really the owner pretty
much does everything i'm not even sure
the cooks even make the sauce seriously
the chef doesn't know the secret behind
the sauce
i've just spotted monger dollars that
can't be right well it must be a
phenomenal octal at twenty dollars yeah
it's good
let's have that as well okay excellent
now stop sweating yeah and relax
okay let's see what we got guys fuji
bacon patties uh one beef one veggie
jerk chicken and one oxtail okay
let's go you guys we need to get the
jamaican patties first please yes dr
morris
everything's soulless it's
it's lacking charm and it's like eating
inside of a an office block
not good tell them let's go they're
they're going they can't go any faster
do you have the jack sauce hanging out
right now
dad yes dr morris we need the next plate
are you working on this yes dr morris
okay beef patty yep we've got a little
bit of mild jerk sauce there and this is
the veggie patty
okay i'll leave you to enjoy those thank
you
absolutely gross that sauce is dreadful
[Music]
pastry's raw soggy pile of dough they
would [ __ ] kidnap me if i served that
in jamaica right now
how are the paddies i mean sauce is
dreadful i don't like it myself it's
like a gloop the sad news about the pate
the pastry is undercooked
this hideous hideous let me get rid of
these for you and this one is the jerk
chicken hot flashes
is that the same sauce yes try that away
do something take this away thank you
look at my rice it looks like a silicone
implant perfectly formed
guys do not put any more jerk sauce on
his plate he hates it
[Music]
oh nasty
not an ounce of seasoning there
cold how's our signature dish blandish
cold chicken
disgusting overcooked rice and when was
that chicken cooked i couldn't tell you
to be honest with you go and ask doctor
this is dry as hell will do thank you
when was the chicken my doctor
what
it
you know why jerk chicken is dry in
jamaica it's supposed to be dry he
doesn't eat jamaican food every day i
eat it every day so i don't know what he
knows of jerk chicken this is our oxtail
student lima beans yeah cartilage
everywhere
what a mess
twenty dollars
how's the oxtail sadly
nothing's been trimmed so it's full of
fat
bland
and the temperature i mean everything
across the board here was sort of barely
lukewarm okay let me get rid of that for
you what an embarrassment
it sucks man like i've i've made points
about this life everything they said
you've already said before yeah i'm just
glad that i was right you know
exactly i'm okay
doctor i would like a word with you
i'm not afraid of chef ramsay i'd like
to talk to you and kyo even if he had
horns i wouldn't be afraid of him okay
i'm i'm embarrassed
i walk in a dining room that felt cold
and just flat when the food arrived
soulless
everything
was horrendous
barely loot warm
dry and tasteless
it's an insult to jamaica
the patties the actual pastry one side
was raw
as for the jerk source
disgusting
i'm gonna say this um from the get-go i
always felt that everything should be
fresh cooked order okay
could you be quiet he's talking
okay let's move on shall we i've got
bigger issues
honestly
hot flashes
isn't that a system of menopause
you can not necessarily not necessarily
it depends on how you perceive it forget
the strange name
that's dreadful jerk chicken dry just a
minute
let me set you straight
most jerk chicken in jamaica are dry
as a matter of fact
let me finish i feel
that the jerk chicken that we do are
more moist than the one they do in
jamaica now let me tell you something
also let me finish let me finish my
sentence first
mostly dry i can accept
dry and edible i can't
i'm ready for an argument because i am
not going to sit here and kiss your ass
for trying to tell me that is a jamaican
jerk chicken you're trying to literally
no no no i'm not trying to lecture i
wouldn't walk into your hospital and
attempt to tell you your job i am
telling you
i don't know what kind of herb from
jamaica you've been smoking
but that is disgusting crap
[Music]
chef ramsay came to this jamaican
restaurant hoping to find food rich in
flavor but instead it was blandish
not surprisingly he had a heated
discussion with the owner most jerk
chicken in jamaica are dry let me tell
you something also let me finish let me
finish my sentence first that is
disgusting crap
still with a bad taste in his mouth chef
ramsay returns to kingston cafe to see
how it operates in a dinner service
where does the food um serve from the
window it's right there that's the
window there
you're kidding me
try to work with what we got
jesus christ exactly
stuffed jerk coconut rum shrimp as the
first orders come into the kitchen okay
let's go you guys let's go kingston
cafe's complimentary salads get sent out
to the diners folks your first course
comes with every meal it's difficult to
eat out of this glass this salad i
ordered is it going to be like
similar to this it's going to be a
little similar it is can i change my
order of the store
what the [ __ ] is that in the martini
glass the salad
salad
daniel yes
who put the salad in a martini glass
is there a doctor in the house
how many glasses there's trees in the
corner there that they take
oh my god you are kidding me
jesus christ
who's doing all this
oh my good
god
um garden if you continue like that
jesus christ actually gonna appear i
hope so because i think that's what's
needed right now
dressing a salad takes seconds tell me
what's wrong with that it gets soggy and
it's nasty
turn around and tell the owner it's
soggy and it's nasty
it doesn't mean that it's really bad
because he's never seen something like
this before i want you dressed in the
salad in a bowl okay
even though he was just planning on
observing chef ramsay can't control
himself and institutes his first change
we've got fresh salads dressed to order
and in a bowl well done excellent but dr
morris make sure it is still the woman
in charge can you give a better piece of
chicken
micromanaging whenever and wherever
possible is that warm it tastes like hot
water this is not jamaican there's no
taste can i have another piece of
chicken i don't like you don't like this
okay
they didn't like this
two old people right here
if they're not jamaican they're not
gonna like it
dr morris doesn't really like to hear a
lot of complaints about the food
she does what she
knows and wants to do
what is that there
chicken breast
daniel yes when was that cooked that was
cooked yesterday
jesus christ doctor yes i can't believe
we're doing this
that was cooked last night it looks like
a giraffe's tongue
okay
it makes me feel validated i guess that
the points that i've been making for
months are the points that he's making
now did you have a dog at home
don't feed them that
[Music]
kirani just come over here okay
now
keaney he's really getting me very upset
suppose i punch him out because let me
finish excuse right let me finish keoni
all he did kiane please be quiet first
of all he wants us to cook everything
fresh why can't you do that you can't
yes you can jamaican food cannot be
cooked fresh every day do you understand
that
mom we'll finish this later
[Music]
what is that there
oh my god you are kidding me bags
everywhere
christ almighty
oh please
what's that in the microwave right
four days
when i first worked here i was like oh
no
really
bags
come on
what's the addiction to bags is it a
medical thing like donating blood in
bags uh everything we've got is like in
bags where do you want to put it then if
you're now going to tell me that rice
dates better in a bag inside the steamer
madam i'm really sorry
but you've lost the plot
i don't like when you disrespect me so
if you can tell me where you think i've
disrespected you you told me that i was
crazy upstairs
i'll tell you why
the practices and how you're running a
restaurant is packed with stupidity
i didn't say that you are demented
didn't say anything like that at all
say
like this that's what you said to me
right
let me finish
if i say that to you how would you feel
i'm not a delicate daily player's gonna
take everything you say personally but
let me tell you something the practices
are ludicrous
can i just show you something
ready no answer
just just feel that
it's frozen
it couldn't be well okay okay it should
not it should not be frozen well it is
frozen no no no don't tell me okay okay
another show no i've got to finish my
sentence
frozen solid disgusting overcooked
chicken you're resisting it that's fine
no no i'm trying to say it should not be
frozen if they did it yesterday i
understand okay but i've just told you
it is right now you're running a
hospital kitchen full of bags
[ __ ] that i'm out of here
he may say i'm crazy but certain things
he says about jamaican food i disagree
with him i'm not crazy
i think the doctor needs a doctor
[Music]
who put the salad in a martini glass
after a very revealing dinner service
you're running a hospital kitchen full
of bags chef ramsay knows that kingston
cafe will never overcome its problems
unless dr morris realizes she is causing
the sickness not the cure so mission
number one this morning is a quick visit
to the doctor's office located right
next door to the restaurant
good morning oh good morning do you want
to come here come on when chef ramsay
came to my office i was surprised
because i did not expect him to come
back
okay
you're so smart but you're unaware of
the dramatic change that's needed
to reposition this business
why are you so stubborn
i'm not stubborn
practices you thought were correct last
night
are backwards you're in denial well um
i'm not in denial because i i'm not in
denial i'm not here to fight you well
i'm here to help you okay just
help me understand where you are
financially
what have you put into that restaurant
in the last three years
probably over three hundred thousand
dollars
you know i just been using my credit
card i borrowed money to just to
maintain the restaurant so how much
longer can you continue along these
lines probably a month
but that doesn't mean i'm going to quit
well you may not have a choice does your
team does your son does your management
understand okay my son doesn't tell you
the honest truth
my son he's only telling you what he
thinks you want to hear i appreciate you
telling me he doesn't tell you that he's
not dependable and doesn't show up
really no he doesn't you don't
understand well i won't understand
unless you tell me you know you don't
understand what i'm going to you ask him
to do anything he argues if i say a he
args about b do you know how i'm hurt
that i have my kids who i have
sacrificed my life for
and
they don't follow through on things that
they need to do and
i have to be doing everything well this
is a huge amount of pressure on one
pair of shoulders isn't cuony worried
about you in terms of i don't think he
does i think the servers worry about me
more than my son does
and you know what hurts me is because my
mom died when i was 10.
[Music]
and i didn't have a mom when i grew up
and i just grew up and be determined to
be somebody when i grew up and you are
you did it and you accomplished it
former olympian
radiologist doctor come on
don't let
the negativity in the restaurant destroy
your self-esteem
no wonder
you're agitated no wonder
you're deeply concerned
the pressure on your shoulders is
ridiculous
and you've done everything
before this restaurant right in your
life you've got every right to continue
with that self-esteem and you're not
going to be dragged down by that
restaurant
may be the first time in your life
doctor that you need help and i'm here
to do that for you
okay i appreciate that
let's not
clash i'm here to help
okay okay i appreciate that
good and i'm sorry i appreciate your
honesty don't be sorry come on come here
come here
come on
i really feel like i can trust him now
and that really means a lot to me
because i'm i'm not used to
asking for help
[Music]
june is in pain she's desperate and
she's got so much riding on her
shoulders the big question for me is how
committed is her son to helping his mum
[Music]
curie yeah i'm gonna get straight to the
point what do you want out of this
restaurant
and how much are you committed
to helping it turn around
if you would have met me when the
restaurant first opened it would have
been a completely different vibe in what
way
i mean like i was really passionate
about this thing i really was i was like
look mom this is a viable business and i
pushed so hard for it and i wanted her
to see that i was right but she doesn't
want to approach the business in a way
that'll make it work you seem to be in
competition with your mother it's
it's the nature of our relationship are
you aware of the financial mess that
your mother's in
she won't tell me
this place is days away from closing
[Music]
she has horrendous credit card bills
right her retirement's a jeopardy
[Music]
and let me tell you something the most
important lady in my life is my mother
right
and what she's done for me has been
extraordinary hasn't your mum done more
than you could ever imagine
absolutely and that's coming from a lady
that had no mom
so drop the bravado and focus on your
family because if this restaurant goes
down you're going down with it got it
all right
thank you
he's definitely right and i know that
she needs help love my mother to death
and i'm not leaving you know her to
handle this by herself
[Music]
after important breakthrough
conversations with yuna and keone oh my
gosh
chef ramsay looks to energize the
restaurant and improve the quality of
the food so tonight's dinner service
will feature a barbecue on the patio
with keone at the helm that's what
you'll be wearing later don't dirty it
all right i want everyone in the
neighborhood lifting their windows up
and
wow where's that smell coming from by
running a delicious barbecue outside
chef ramsay wants yuna to realize the
merits of serving jamaican food that is
not only completely fresh but rich in
flavor so the restaurant's running in
the restaurant and the barbecue is
taking place on the patio any questions
no chef okay jump in have a little taste
wow that looks amazing it smells good
out here the chicken is good that means
a lot coming from you
i like the chicken it's different but it
was good i would give him a b-plus
but i'm worried because people come in
like the other one also
so you don't want to change too much
okay you're excited yeah yes
good let's go because we're half an hour
as the doors open for dinner customers
are offered the regular menu in the
dining room for the special barbecue
menu served on the patio at any time you
can just go up and start serving
yourself roasted corn with chili lime
butter the colors and the smells
everything was vibrant and exciting that
looks so good it's pretty phenomenal
it's a really good idea though while
keoni oversees the barbecue which is
already generating excitement i need
shrimp they're defrosting right now head
chef daniel and the kitchen staff are
unfortunately stuck in their same old
habits what in the [ __ ] is that cups and
bags cups and bags i thought the only
thing that went in bags were bodies i
hate those bags
oh gross so where's the fresh rice for
tonight
we're using the same rice that we made
yesterday
[ __ ] how
i'm extremely frustrated i wanted to
make fresh beans and rice today it was
not the decision dr morris wanted me you
got no fresh rice on there okay
apparently doctor's orders are use the
old rice in the bag i'm sorry
hope they get our food out soon in spite
of the frequent use of the microwave
guys it's been 20 minutes on a order of
rudy shrimp we're just waiting for it
the kitchen struggles to get food out to
their customers i could have grown a
beard by the time they bring my meal in
the dining room the the atmosphere was a
little like down where the food kept
taking so long people just weren't
generally happy whereas when i poked my
head outside to the patio people were
laughing they were having fun it was
almost like two different restaurants
tonight
that was really good really good chicken
jerry great news look how popular
barbie's been coming right and that's
smell
nice makes you feel like you're back in
jamaica
from jamaica to depressing after what
seemed like an eternity customers in the
dining room are finally receiving their
food
but it doesn't appear to be worth the
wait the fish is really dry i think it
may be overcooked overcooked okay i'll
let them know right now
what's wrong with that they said it's
too dry enough it's just gone out daniel
what she just wants to try something
else
jesus recommend the barbecue we've got a
stunning piece of salmon out there
cooked you want to try that don't get it
now quickly okay dry and overcooked is
that still the is that the frozen stuff
yes it's the frozen stuff
there's robbery she's absolutely right
thoroughly frustrated chef ramsay jumps
into action and puts together an entree
of barbecue salmon let's hope she enjoys
i can't believe we're serving barbecue
food in the dining room there we are
chef ramsay plated it for you oh my god
there you are okay thank you
oh my god
that's so good
excuse me
how is that it's great is it great
[Music]
and the verse our hair is wonderful it's
beautiful i really appreciate it good
good girls
change is not easy you know but i was
really impressed with how many people
enjoy the barbecue tonight so i'm
willing to
allow him to tell me how i can make it
better
okay
tonight was a tale of two restaurants
oona let's hear from the boss everybody
out in the patio we're very pleased
inside that was different inside
everything was bad yeah you're right
we did confirm the barbecue worked
clearly tonight we added something
but we might have to take something away
because it's been bugging me from the
first minute i walked in here
hang on a second yeah
irritating
bloody hell what is it
does anybody know
could it be
[Music]
what what the [ __ ] is going
on gosh
[Music]
fed up with the amount of food that is
being reheated oh my god you are kidding
me chef ramsay have to take something
away hang on a second yeah is determined
to get rid of this damaging practice
[ __ ]
[Music]
there's more plastic here
than in beverly hills
say goodbye to your bags
[Music]
looking at all that food first thing
that comes to me was dollars
[Music]
yes i
want you
to succeed tonight it stops we get rid
of the bags we have a simple practice of
cooking raw ingredients on the day and
serving them
trust me
if we don't make
major changes
on relaunching this restaurant
we don't stand a hope in hell
good night
see you in the morning good night thank
you jesus
it was kind of hard to take
i think it's really going to work out dr
morris but he wants me to trust him
so i'm going to do that
with dr morris seemingly on board chef
ramsay and his team spend the next nine
overnight hours bringing the caribbean
spirit into kingston cafe
good morning good morning
here on this very patio we had a taste
of success right yeah yep now the idea
is to get that success in through there
ready yeah yeah let's go
here we go straight through oh my god
this is fantastic chef ramsay
transformed this entire room into the
caribbean let's start with the caribbean
blue we removed the artwork from the
walls and got that cabana effect that
carabine feel yes oh my god i feel like
i'm at the beach you know all i need now
is a nice cocktail in my hand and it'll
be a great day oh my god oona if you say
oh my god any more times trust me he
will appear
the first thing he said to me when i
arrived good
job if you continue like that jesus
christ actually gonna appear
oh my god have a look at the table tops
gone is that white linen it's a
casual exciting fun
inviting dining room we've got some
really nice woven still placemats and
beautiful china and look what's on every
table
it's just like a jerk sauce that's
brilliant
wow
oh thank you
it's pretty phenomenal completely happy
for my mother you know that's the
biggest thing
along with the new decor chef ramsay has
replaced the tasteless uninspiring old
menu and in its place a tasty fresh menu
that celebrates caribbean cuisine please
take a look at the kingston cafe oh my
god new dishes that is so beautiful just
have a look at the vibrant colors first
off yes it's really beautiful more
importantly it's fresh a taste of
jamaican platy for everything on there
you could wish for in the jamaican
restaurant yeah the patties are
phenomenal the kingston special barbecue
that'll be done from outside barbecue
chicken kingfish and a tamarind
marinated skirt steak it's beautiful it
looks good right yes yes so are you
gonna look good
because we have a little fun with these
beautiful yes yes
look at that
i'm matt
when you swept in black we won't see it
thank you yes yes now hold that
pass them along we've got your names in
there this shirt's definitely more
casual feel than the white shirt and
thai and i really think this has got to
go start tasting
that fish is perfect yeah it really is
this is the best jamaican food i've ever
had this is actually probably the best
food full stop i've ever had i love it
taste this chef ramsay has opened so
many avenues for me that i could never
ever repay him for his kindness one more
little surprise come true when i first
arrived driving by i missed the place it
wasn't clear enough
time to make a statement
to pasadena
ready
look at
that oh it's beautiful you can see it
from miles away yes that's true okay
oh dude
it was really exciting seeing a new sign
that was so visible
and colorful thank
you it so much now there's no way that
anybody cannot see the sign let's make
this service
an amazing service yes okay
with chef ramsay's vision complete it's
time to relaunch this pasadena
restaurant how are you guys today
welcome to the new and improved kingston
cafe as you can see we've got the new
menus down i'll go with the jerk chicken
the barbecue we're going to do a taste
of jamaica all right here we go all
right you guys we've got a tasty
jamaican platter barbecued jerk chicken
bbq tomato skirt steak may i have some
chips please
only minutes into dinner service imani
appetizer platter
appetizers are leaving the kitchen at a
steady pace tuna ceviche and lobster
bitters are gonna come that's really
good and more importantly customers are
thrilled with what they are receiving
that is so good isn't it but the real
pressure is about to hit getting backed
up on ticket jesus royce and head chef
daniel is already a little flustered
come on guys
k-13
k-13
they already got their food k-13 already
got their food oh no
k-13 has already had their food why are
we sending through twice who's
organizing this it is me i need one
person to start taking control yes i beg
you yes what table is going next please
stand for p4 so p4 good so let's all
sing off the same page and we send p4
together yes i was mixing up some orders
sending things to the wrong tables and
that's that's unexcusable let's do the
red snapper i've got that
here the velcro red snappier okay
oh
no it's black as hell
why it overclocked i'm sorry chef look
at me
just tell me why so i can help you let
me i so want you to succeed so do i chef
not serving food like that you don't
it's relaunch night at the kingston cafe
and after a promising start oh no head
chef daniel has lost his composure jesus
and his standards he's black as hell
things just weren't going the way we
thought they would get overcooked and
you gave it to the girl to send all
right let me redo it
[Music]
that table over there
they were seated after us and
they've already eaten
the food wasn't coming out on time and
it made us look better it was going
downhill fast guys i'm sorry about this
guys i can assure you it is coming out
okay kiana what about the people been
here for our mom what can we do
two seconds look two seconds come here
i need someone getting a grip of this
now and [ __ ] waking them up because
we make ourselves look stupid right yeah
dan's got to step over the plate yeah
and you need to get them together a
little bit yeah running around yeah all
right yeah we're sinking and we're
falling behind
all right
dan please just make sure that anything
that you're doing you're doing two up or
three up i think we're following you
fine tony's your man exactly you're the
eighth yes off the same [ __ ] page yes
yeah this is what i need you guys start
doing get rolls of chips and we're going
to start giving them to the table so
they can munch on them while they're
waiting on the food okay thank you thank
you thank you everybody gets chips
there's a little chips to hold you over
this is really good
hey guys there's also dessert that's
floating around okay so make somebody
else do it come on give me the ticket i
take it in the back and get it done no
i'm mom no
you're not knowing what's going on mom
i definitely want my mom to understand i
can make this thing work
walk around talk to the guests you're
more important i can't talk to them no
no no no no no you can't mom because i
don't want to argue with you you like to
argue this isn't an argument okay what
number is this okay seven eleven the
barber bomb
stand away from this area you can't help
mom not right now i need two seconds
with you please came back right now got
to let him do it
got to let kion do it he's trying thank
you yo he's showing that level of
commitment let him do it screw the dying
room okay 30 seconds bobbing around each
little table wow okay let him do it let
him find his voice i just want to finish
this order right here guys it's going
too slow dad yeah i understand that you
can put more shrimp in there than that
right no i see two you can at least spit
one more in there this is almost an hour
on this ticket there you go
gionee's leadership has helped stabilize
the kitchen can you work on furby
patties into jerk wings allowing
customers to finally get a taste of the
new kingston cafe
oh that looks amazing
i need uh another coconut rum shrimp
finally
we just need to finish this how is
everybody doing we love it and we're
enjoying just that
good i really appreciate that i
guarantee to you it we're gonna be so
much faster and better okay
the fact that i've opened up and is
committed to keep his menu
that's a big thing for me
well let me tell you i grew up on
parties in jamaica in kingston that
squash party was absolutely amazing it
took me back to my childhood really yes
thank you guys it was great
all right guys dinner service is over
[Music]
okay what a night
yeah but we had a buzz
out there on the patio and a buzz in the
dining room right
the customers clearly love the food
that's good clearly we did have a
problems
but there was one person that did step
up and helped in a big way to turn
things around
[Music]
thank you
yes thank you good job tonight kiana
really stepped up to the plate i'm so
proud of them
he did a fantastic job to all of you
cook your hearts out
and serve with a smile
good luck
thank you
thank you
oh now can i say a little word with you
through there yes
thank you it's been a gigantic step
forward and we are only going to get
better
now
kione he proved he's capable i know he
is very intelligent young man i know but
you have a tough decision in front if
you're going to make him part of the
business then commit to doing that
okay
either you make him feel like you're a
partner in the business
or you let him go you cut the open
strings one or the other okay okay your
decision okay now there's one more thing
[Music]
do you fancy a race
oh you want to run yeah okay come on now
i'm joking i'm pulling up oh dogs
god bless you initially i didn't like
chef ramsay i'm telling you trying to
literally let me finish
but now i realize that he has a
wonderful heart
he's going to be so proud of us
when he comes back
what a week
my goodness me i only hope that this
olympian doctor mother can now add
successful restauranteur
to a resume why because she deserves it
big time
let me finish
let me
finish
shortly after chef ramsay's departure
yuna decided to encourage kyoni to
concentrate on his education and step
back from the restaurant you know i'll
always love you don't hear you and i
fight and i
you know of course
yuna however is more dedicated than ever
she is committed to cooking fresh
collaborating with her staff and
maintaining the standards chef ramsay
put in place please enjoy it as long as
i follow what coach ramsey explained to
me what we need to do it has to look
good and it has to taste good the future
of kingston cafe looks great